[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the break room everybody
it's Friday and we're gonna get wild
okay uh this is the nerdy news show that
keeps you up to date up to date on
everything you need to know live from
New Rockstar's headquarters here uh
today we're gonna we've got some some a
rare occurrence of some Wonder Man news
yes that show's still in development
um we've got uh of course a lot of
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania stuff
uh some footage they might hint at some
Kang details we didn't know about before
Coy's excited to talk about it and we're
gonna do maybe the worst Redemption
we've ever chosen to do on this show I
can't stop thinking about it uh we was
worried about the puking as I am happy
about the king oh okay good it's a yin
yang thing they're they're any they're
in Balance uh with me uh to endure all
of this we've got coins here today gonna
try to conquer but we'll see yes just a
human remains Jessica and Tommy
and I'm Zach of course uh okay here's
the Redemption we're doing today guys we
haven't done an eating kind of weird
thing in a minute and somebody suggested
this and whenever we find that person
again they will be punished but uh the
name of this is the mother shake okay uh
we started out this is just uh these
little shot glasses uh of just this is
uh ice cream uh some mixed berries and
some milk a normal nice kind of
milkshake Vibe now half of this is still
in the blender over there uh and every
time we hit a Redemption threshold in
super chats uh more ingredients are
gonna get added to this the Super Snake
they'll all be really delicious right no
Tommy they won't uh first up we've got
Clamato and broccoli getting dumped in
uh you can see some of the items that
will be coming up later why is there a
question mark that's uh sardines a
mystery ingredient that producer John
won't tell us about uh and then you can
kind of see it in the background It's
the final boss uh it is the hottest hot
Ones hot sauce oh God we'll be dumped
into the mother shake at the end again
each time we hit that these new
ingredients go in it gets re-blended we
take another shot of it it's uh a
terrible idea
I'm gonna do this for my sanity this is
the good one I want to remember the good
times cheers
pretty that's good no everyone keep your
pennies in your pocket
what does that mean all these trash bags
they can't come up with the cash to make
us drink anything yeah well that was
tasty yeah that one was good all the
rest from now on not so good uh so again
if you decide to throw in super chats
people both what's our first Benchmark
for it to be discussed we had 200 we're
doing that next round of really
unpleasant ingredients oh God uh but
again like Tommy said that'll never
happen so uh let's get on to some
headlines
yes we've just got a couple quick ones
today uh James Gunn tweeted some of the
comics that are touchstones for the team
please I made a video uh on my YouTube
page that was the Deep dives into the
comics that I think are going to be in
it based on his tones so he talked about
like you know Supergirl woman of
tomorrow he had some specific Comics but
he mainly used imagery uh for some of
the the smaller announcements so we
specifically named a few and then used
imagery for the others so I dove into
those books again reread those and then
thought of other Comics that were
totally like those and basically made a
giant must read Pantheon list and so far
I am exactly accurate every single one
that he's tweeted out since I have not
had a miss so every book He's reference
I've gotten right so I'm really really I
mean both in the proud of myself way but
also in the hope for this universe way
he's got such a vision that even die
hard comic fans can shape what other
books he's referencing like if you know
one book that well you also know he's
living in this world but that means like
that's a that's a Precision Arrow of a
universe because there's thousands and
thousands of comics books the fact that
every book He's referenced is akin to
another in a very specific way it's
really exciting so I'm actually going to
make a giant thread like he's doing and
also and I this isn't said to separate
comic you know worlds but this is I
think the most comic books have been
talked about in the 15 years that comic
book movies have been thriving like oh
wait started all this this is the most
I've seen Comics trending this is the
most I've seen comic book covers so I
from the beginning when James Gunn got
announced was excited for comic books
and it is already happening so I'm
really excited for the next two years
I'm really excited to actually talk
about the books themselves so if you
guys want to talk about comic books let
whoever know because I'm I'm there for
you yeah yeah we're excited too and yeah
again it's a great it's going to be a
couple years before we see any of uh
these films especially up on the screen
it gives you something to do in the
meantime study up a little bit if you
read them now you will have forgotten
key plot details by the time the movies
come out and they'll be fresh 50 First
Dates
oh no okay well we're well on our way to
our first round of torture but uh we've
got another uh headline real quick uh
Marvel is reportedly in talks with
director James pencilt I think I'm
saying his name right uh about directing
some episodes for Wonder Man now this
show had previously been announced
Dustin uh Dustin Daniel [__] director
of Sean Chi uh as well as a bunch of
other films right is the executive
producer of this series and is going to
be directing some of the episodes this
James pensold is going to be directing
some of the other episodes he has uh a
raft of uh feature films under his belt
including The Spectacular Now and the
circle as well as he's directed some TV
including master of none so he's a he's
a veteran hand that they've got on board
and um maybe like you know your your
jack Schaefer's and your other kind of
uh veteran TV directors that have worked
in the the MCU Disney Plus World right
he'll come in and be a guiding hand for
that series no it's like how broad those
credits are now is a very different tone
than the circle as well as master of
none I I know his name but I hadn't
realized like that's really good tonally
for Wonder Man because Wonder Man Is So
Meta selfishness
yeah and like if it's kind of like a a
meta Hollywood movie you need somebody
who can like accurately kind of portray
regular Hollywood right yeah someone
that's uh knowing those different types
of sets like he needs to know TV and
film because he's directing a TV show
that has film elements yes and again we
don't know when this series is kind of
slated to come out it hasn't been
announced we can assume we don't know
that much about 2024 right Covenant
chaos is probably going to leak into
2024. uh we know we got white Vision
somewhere we know we got uh Wonder Man
somewhere out there 20 25 for both of us
maybe I think yeah I think they're far
enough away if they're announcing a
director now that usually takes a little
bit of time but also 2025 especially
after the gun announcement is so stacked
like I thought 2023 was crazy and then
they were like what if you get you know
the Batman 2 and your first Avengers
what do we even have in 2024 on Disney
plus uh I mean confirmed I think it's
mostly just goofy cartoons just over and
over again you've been advocating for
that pretty hard time that new goofy now
I just want to mention real quick we
said the director's name is James pencil
yes do you like pencil
yeah well why don't you pencil in these
nuts for an appointment with your mouth
Tommy happy Friday everybody Tommy happy
Friday
way too early in the episode to be doing
this wait till we get some liquefied
squid in our guts okay
um no God I forgot about that I
Gary Watson Aaron storm this is me shame
on all of you uh again we're probably we
are dangerously close to our first round
of gross uh mother shake shots uh but
let's we'll begin our our discussion
here of the episode probably be
interrupted rudely by some gross shots
at some point but uh we got some more
Ant-Man material today they keep they
got this nice steady leak of uh of new
TV spots uh trailer clips uh exclusive
Clips things like that keep coming out
um and so we're actually gonna kind of
react live to it here and uh see if
there's anything new and interesting
that we notice in this latest clip let's
roll tape
a lot has changed about my life
literally saved the world
but right now the only job I want is
being a dad
Scotland do you want to get out of here
and I need to get out of here bring me
what I want what's that
you cannot trust him
I don't care who this guy is I just lost
so much time
he's a Monster who thinks he's a god
everything you call a life
I will burn out of time he's my Cassie
we'll stop him together
you think you can beat me
yeah both pre and and after getting
sucked into the quantum footage yeah
yellow suit there that's the first time
we've seen her like kind of in that
action yeah and I think the last couple
of Clips have shown a lot more giant man
yeah looking shots as well right
oh no oh no Evan's about to deliver
another round of pain for us um
interesting sorry they include uh a
compre in comparison to Gods and
Monsters or Monsters either Gods right
after the announcement that chapter one
of DC is Gods and Monsters that has to
be a coincidence yeah I know this is
funny but we wanted to point out a
couple things that stood out to us the
field like they might be important and
koi has some strong thoughts right
that's the first time they've used
conqueror yes and verbally in writing
anything like that right The Duality
between Avenger and conquerors so it not
only is it our first use of conqueror
we've got the Kang Dynasty to come we
see that you know this is growing but as
we're what two weeks out from this movie
first time using conquer means I think
personally we're gonna end this with him
being the Conqueror something that Scott
does causes him to level up in a really
interesting way and I also think I've
been saying from the beginning that one
sleeve outfit is a different Tang I
think so I think we're gonna meet
multiple kangs I think we might get
certain other variants of Kang that
we've been warned about right we've met
he who remains and we've been warned
about Kang but Kang is a plural there's
literally a council of gangs Kang is a
as an entity like we talked about with
the confusion of like how you can just
be a king but I I'm really curious how
they land the Scarlet Centurion which I
think might get teased oh I don't like
that shot at all oh no okay sorry uh koi
this is Clamato and broccoli has been
added to the shake you know what I bet
you there are some health nuts that make
something close to this one right I mean
I know people that put broccoli in their
smoothies I do
um yeah but I drink clamatos maybe this
will be fine but but uh the Scarlet
Centurion which is being made in that
blender right now it's gonna I think be
a factor in the movie and I also think
we're gonna eventually lead to a mortise
so I'm wondering if this is one of those
post-credit scenes like they usually do
one that ties to this movie and one that
teases another right like there's
usually like a an alley-oop to the next
thing but also one that lives here so
I'm wondering if we get one for the
Marvels because I don't think there's
been one for Guardians I think Guardians
is pretty isolated by itself so I think
the big like whoa is going to be
cosmically leading the models but I
think the one kind of Ant-Man might be a
mortise and I'm wondering if we don't
see him again until Kang Dynasty what if
they like plant a seed of like big bad
like Jonathan Majors like you know
all-powerful s tier and then we don't
see him again for a while and that's
when you know how crazy the stakes are
because we need someone to be a big bad
and I'm not swimmering if you get like
beyonder Doom all of the Mega powerful
because we've got a long time to play
that game so I think this conqueror
which I know I'm reading a lot into
could mean 20 things yeah I also a
couple of quick things I liked
um a a lot of uh Jonathan Majors facial
acting the way we haven't seen yet
there's a little bit more like yeah a
little bit more angry face and like
exactly
he's been pretty stoic in most of the
shots so we have seen the kind of
shooting the blue energy before some of
the fighting shots but a lot of new
stuff there I also love this sequence
right like bring me what I want and then
it doesn't say yeah
they're teasing us with that okay
consistency looks still pretty nice
producer Evan coming in there's some
weird chunks
okay uh first low again this is the
Clamato and broccoli has been added here
I sniffed it I shouldn't have I'll take
mine at the next Redemption I'm lactose
intolerant no
oh it is heavy Clamato this is so
clamato-y
oh no GSU Eagle you don't need to do
that no no no bring off the shakes oh oh
it gets you in the back it's like weight
like it's like it oh no it's a
cacophony
like
that's it no more donations we
appreciate everyone who gave I think I
think like the kamado is the flavor and
then the dairy makes it linger really
yeah I like it the thickness of the
dairy coats your throats shot wrong and
it separates yeah it hasn't gone away
mixing shots I'm gonna have to drink
heavily tonight there's a there's a
wallpaper paste quality to it that is
not as soon as this is over uh luckily
we got another clip to play that'll
maybe give us a moment but I do want to
mention and this is this is masochism
the next level
is a seafood level oh there's both we'll
be adding some pescado to the Clamato
this was a canned eel and canned
sardines is so wrong
eels don't deserve to be canned they
should be free in the ocean helping
Ursula complete her dire dastardly tasks
and none of this stuff should be blended
with ice cream okay uh shame on all of
you drew Bradley match143 stop everyone
stop donating money now I will not eel
ain't gonna touch this tummy this
tummy's been eel free for 38 years and
it ain't about to start now because I'm
39 adio when I was one yeah you're in a
plate full of eel when I turned one who
doesn't uh let's roll this next clip
you know I promised your mom that you
would only use this stuff when one of us
was around it's really dangerous Tech I
know it's dangerous what if the cops
took it from you what if you lost it I
didn't lose the suit you have a suit
wait you have a suit I know how to take
care of myself okay trust me I'm pretty
good at it by now
look I didn't mean it like that
no it's okay it's all right I get it
I just think you should get to have a
normal life
dad
a guy dressed like a bee tried to kill
me in my room when I was six
I've never had a normal life
how about some music
and in that moment all I could think was
how did the Hulk turn me into a baby
will I be a baby forever
am I the Hulk's baby dad are you
listening to your own book but I was
ready for it
hey uh again that that is a I think what
they've been talking about we don't
think that's the very first scene in the
movie but that's an early scene
obviously that's before they get sucked
into the quantum realm kind of minutes
in entirety and a couple things stood
out to us we're way too close to 400
right now I'm sorry I don't mean to
knick knack paddy whack uh quit giving
this dog a bone okay go away
um a couple things that stood out there
you know it's already been kind of
established that like
um you know Cassie we saw those earlier
Clips she's getting out of some kind of
a jail Jam type of situation maybe
they're driving her home possibly from
that in in this clip and there's a lot
of this like you haven't been around dad
pounding of not just him being absent
but also the ramifications of that like
as he's blaming himself probably for
going to prison so he's definitely
blaming himself for having a super super
yeah but it seems like he's blaming
himself for missing her and any action
she makes he's going to you know be be
masochistic but sadistic about so I'm
really wondering if the thing he's
trying to do with Kang is to go back
before I'm wondering if the time is like
to miss the blip or to go to like her
childhood again yeah because Cassie
looks like she's this close to recording
an album with Everclear
Father of Mine uh she'd probably have a
newer reference than that uh 25 year old
one she looks like she's this close to
recording an album with BTS okay uh
noted angst uh Merchants oh my God film
juice put us over the edge your enemy
but I do want to point out that Nick uh
requested in their 50 Super Chat for
Jessica to get to sit this one out and I
feel like we have to honor that I
respect I don't want to let her sit it
out but I feel like if people are given
50 we gotta we have to honor no Evan if
anyone wants to donate somebody to let
me sit it out that would be really great
uh one last thing while we get this and
they're they're about to get so gross oh
I'm not a puking thinking well we wait
for that uh yeah a couple things
um also the whole like Scott doesn't
know that she has a suit yeah that's
interesting right do you think she's
going straight to Hank yeah her suit she
calls him she's Sweeting them up if you
butter well you know he wants to do
anything he can't have more control of
the family because he was absent and
he's definitely always been like a
little manipulative like he was with
cross and everything else so Scotty
Doesn't Know grumpy Hank and are we
assuming because those are the the
strange thing about her being like you
weren't around dad I guess we were
talking about we don't know if her mom
and stepdad were we don't know if Bobby
Carnival Judy Greer we're we're blipped
or we're just you know negligent because
frankly if they weren't blipped she
doesn't have that much to complain about
right she had two parents seriously
that's a pretty sweet deal who are like
seemingly great parents yeah uh but
maybe if one or both of them were that
blender who would have been raising her
uh also I can tell Evan is keeping all
the juice involved in the oven we don't
can't see if you're generous don't be
generous be stingy with the fish oh my
God I imagine Judy Greer got blimp so
there's a father figure it'd be
interesting to have the dichotomy of
like the cop Father Figure while the uh
you know Heist man dad is out you're not
my real dad not my real dad conversation
on top of the blip no real dad was
blapped yeah
uh I do want to Circle back to the
previous clip we had Kenny talked about
right like all the two previous Ant-Man
movies had this Heist element and we can
only assume you know we see all these
action shots all this kind of cool stuff
happening in the quantum realm we assume
maybe some of those shots are in service
to a heist whether that's like go get
the thing that Kang is requiring you to
get or go get the thing to defeat King
right right or both Maybe here's a shot
of the thing and for watching us watch
what we're about to suffer through and
I'm struggling from Winston puke 585
which I hope is a Rochester New York
reference and uh we gave them that name
oh Mr puke stunning
Winston puke is that great this is a
great name oh God the next one is
Mystery ingredient and root beer with a
shrimp topper is that like a shrimp
cocktail like are we dipping a hole
there's no uh World in which that's uh
also I just want to say uh the character
Winston puke plays in the bike black
panther franchise yeah and puku I'm just
saying if you got you yeah I mean how
appropriate that he's super chatting on
this day of all days when we were all
we're so honored to have to have a real
life movie star
um real quick while we wait for this
next round of of really gross uh Shake
shots uh we want to shout out both Tommy
and I are ripping some of the newest
items on the first shot oh and Jessica's
got the great hoodie on I didn't even
see that
um this is our Our Last of Us shirt uh
was it say look for the light of course
the Firefly
um uh catchphrase that's available at
nerdraia.shop and Tommy's got one of the
cool quantumania shirt designs this is
the one inspired by wasp it says Cosmic
Atomic oh yeah uh we a little lotus
flower in the bag yes oh we've been
talking about how uh you know grab this
now you can wear it opening night yeah
and when you see me there we can run up
and touch our shirt Graphics that
Mommy's going to every show like oh man
wow that guy's been outside every
theater all night wow with his hands
like this tell me tell me short Graphics
rubbed off
no they're actually they're made very uh
they're very high quality yeah they will
not rev off you can rub we can rub
chests up to a thousand times before I
guarantee the shirts compromised even a
little and that's the bechtold brand
guaranteed
uh lots of cool stuff over there head
over to uh nerd Ryan dot Shop painting
come on you're a friend come on uh and
also I don't know don't Evan Evan
just said he feels bad about it this one
doesn't have shrimp right no okay so I
will have to tag out the shrimp one
because I'm just gonna own that up front
I'm gonna try today no why did I smell
it it smells like the bathroom in a Long
John Silver's
oh
no no
nope
there's so many chunks nope
I'm just coming up a little bit no she's
swimming Upstream there's a salmon
situation okay good you might need it my
shrimping I think I love Seafood so much
that I didn't mind oh get out of here
Jessica
so quick and I was like oh
no there's so many little chunks of eel
on my teeth no guys it's all right I
didn't love it but I love to see it
Tommy
on the ocean because it tastes like
seafood yeah
uh again the next level has a can of
root beer which doesn't make any sense
it's gross to throw in a soda in this
deep end uh and the shrimp topper by the
way is is dried shrimp that I've been
told are going to be floating on the top
like uh sprinkles on a cupcake
um
Tommy's done okay
he's praying
aren't we all uh Tommy's reliving his
college Years
um uh so we we were talking uh we're
gonna uh try out a new segment you know
there there was there was not a lot of
news today but this was a fun news week
and so we wanted a way to kind of
revisit the great stories of the week uh
but maybe put a new Twist on them so
we've prepared uh all the headlines of
the week but in joke format like a
little like as if it's a little uh late
night talk show I don't know you know
what
[Laughter]
from his uh Tommy's in a bad way I was
like did you
did
so much eel there's these are
these are Big Shots these are half shot
glasses and yet that was 85 yield I
think I've eaten the whole eel and
you're still giving money this is what
bothers me about you people you're still
giving generously Jamie Riley Travis
smile people claim to be my friends in
the chat we formed bonds we form
relationships I've come to your
dumpsters I've dropped off banana peels
for you to eat I've dropped off orange
peels for you to eat and this is how you
thank me uh endless Mike I hope not
townsman I love your name but uh don't
don't appreciate the super chat today
match one for three and then film juice
my Nemesis you show your face again on
this day of all days go back to where
you came from film juice uh but again
we've prepared some jokes uh based on
the headlines of the week to share
uh Tommy do you want to kick it off or
should I start I'd love to thanks Zach
multiple injuries were reported on the
set of the Netflix squid Game reality
shows contestants complained of harsh
conditions well
shouldn't have let Joss Whedon direct it
then
hey
uh uh knock in the cabin opens at movie
theaters uh this weekend we're excited
for that uh Jessica's gonna have a
breakdown
um uh out on the channel next week uh of
course knock in the cabin the shellfish
themed porn parody is already streaming
[__] out and crabbing
them
is that a long is that a long way to go
was that a bit of a strategy
an animal goddammit yeah there's eels
trying to get out of my belly James Gunn
said this week that previous DC
leadership had [__] around Henry
Cavill a lot of DC fans would pay very
good money to see Henry Cavill get
[__] around hey oh you put the boxers
on the outside
oh Tommy you're a part of this one uh
the Gladiator sequel has officially been
slated for November of 2024. it's of
course gonna uh follow Russell Crowe's
character's son uh in the sequel when
asked for his thoughts Tommy Victor had
this to say
Oh no just kidding oh yeah there you go
there you go come on Jessica
um we got our first look at the poster
for the Fast and Furious X this week
prominently featuring uh only Vin Diesel
holding a rosary when asked for common
Jesus said don't blame me for this Ranch
oh Jesus don't be a hater Jesus oh no
evidence they raced again we're over the
it what's Happening Here I still have
that's the one I gotta take out because
the shrimps are saying I just love the
flavor Society I'm gonna tag out of this
one okay
cocaine Berry
that's just the joke
we'll release a 15 second preview on
Super Bowl Sunday ironically a 15 second
preview is also what most cocaine
dealers give you to get you hooked on
cocaine hey yo
that's just a fact not a joke another uh
okay we're at this segment with the oh
no the mystery ingredient what's the
reveal oh
honestly that should have been the bit
it was just paper going in and again
there's still ice cream in this shake
okay ice cream and milk now mixed with
these things
um back to knock at the cabin uh coming
up this weekend you know if you're
unaware it's a it's a movie about an
apocalypse called kidnapping a family on
vacation of course that was adapted from
the Memoir of tubby Beck told about his
last trip to New Jersey oh yes lots of
kidnappings I can't get [__] out and
crabbing out of my mouth and crap it
started strong I gotta I gotta do this
one for my boy because I'm from Boston
so I feel like I have to be the one to
deliver this important news Tom Brady
has retired at 45 which is too bad
because 45 is right about the age when
your balls start to deflate for real
yeah I just went gay uh Tommy you have a
couple birthdays you'd like I sure I'd
like to wish Warwick Davis a happy 53rd
birthday of course the willow star was
going to take a celebratory job but
instead he walked
he walked think about it there it is
there it is
and of course Anthony Russo of the Russo
Brothers also turned 53 today but we
hope that's not his
end game
oh I get that one
they're the they're the same birthday
Warwick Davis and Anthony Russo wow I
like that both boards with both both
barely made the 70s sport a 70s trial
child of the 70s I like this as I hope
it happens on the heels of the gentle
minions fad that saw young men wearing
suits to watch minions Magic Mike Last
Dance fans have announced they'll be
attending the movie with sock stuff down
their pants
I've been wearing nothing but socks
thick other Ox
the boys producer Seth Rogan said an
interview that Marvel films aren't for
him because they're aimed at children he
prefers the high brow thought-provoking
adult fare like Green Hornet yeah yes
Seth Rogen yes which we enjoy the boys
but no need to drag Marvel films okay
just do your thing and let them do their
thing uh this this is one I particularly
enjoyed if you're a fan of the
Paddington franchise like we are here uh
oh no oh no Evan oh of course Ben Wishaw
the actor telted actor from the James
Bond franchise who also plays the voice
of Paddington uh was talking this week
you know they were supposed to start
shooting patented in three last year
they haven't even started yet some would
say the movie has been marma delayed oh
and finally marmalade I went Marmaduke
and finally and this will be my last
joke and last moment oh I can already
smell it on the heels of Ant-Man and the
WASP Wes Anderson has announced his own
genre film aunt Pam and the Wasps a
movie about a Connecticut act in a crime
fighting book club Tilda Swinton will be
playing every role Clump Style
no no no no I want to see Tilda Swinton
do it and when asked for a comment Wired
Magazine said oh delightful oh make mine
oh no okay I don't know can did we get a
shot of this that there are there are
dried shrimp floating on the entire
little tiny shrimps look I'll eat this
floating in the glass oh man all right
this I'll be honest this is gonna be it
for me uh this will end me
the last one was a journey into darkness
here we go oh God the smell ah can you
guys smell it through the screen I
smelled it why did I smell it don't do
it close your nose close your nostrils
Oh no you're super hard to eat that I
thought oh Zach don't show it no I can't
food it oh no oh
there was so much shrimp Zach made sauce
oh God and there's so much Wasabi I'm
still chewing the shrimp
having third day in already making an
impact oh god oh it's so salty oh God
after you spit it into the cup and
you're eating it back you're like a baby
cat yeah
this is It's Times Like These that you
remember that shrimp are related to
insects and also today's dashville's
birthday so happy birthday happy
birthday dad I don't give a [__] about
that
frog
it's so chewy I'm glad I did I love you
dash so I do give a [__] these were
dried shrimp which are like meant to be
cooked not eaten
like direct they have to be rehydrated
oh God in honor of dashel
I'm gonna puke not a dashel I'm gonna
name my five favorite Star Trek
characters for you right now oh number
five check off okay number four
Han Solo number three Uhura
number two Dr McCoy
and number one seven of nine okay wow no
Captain's getting in there thank you
endless Mike okay thank you Travis miles
just take another shot Jamie Riley
you're my hero Angela Holmberg
apparently it's Friday Payday for the
entire chat jumping in
um
Tommy from Oscar producer Brandon
that smells like shrimp those were the
eels that was a salty Seafood
ice cream producer is you know what that
son of a [__] picks a day he's not here
yeah now he's super chatting like his
life depends on oh no there's we made
the other thing that we made the
Cuttlefish round no and really they say
wait what is this what what is this
round this is Cuddle cuttlefish and
something else too right
Derek Derek
for Derek
Derek if I gotta do this shot and you
just make 200 I'm gonna spend 30 seconds
roasting you yes Edwards more like team
Derek Jacob
that's right Derek Edwards you got two
first names find a last name
more like Derek Ted
and Derek dead oh no Evan please go easy
um Derek Edwards uh throwing in two red
uh devil smiley faces you go to hell
Derek Edwards and those two Devils
that's the devil's threesome if I've
ever seen one go to hell
we got a couple more uh jokes here
um
actually this is your villain oh uh
no actually we do we did read all the
jokes let's just make up oh wait wait
wait uh Dave Batista of course started
knocked to the cabin uh I've been doing
a lot of interviews and he did an
interview we talked about earlier this
week uh where he complained that he
never gets offered any romantic comedy
roles uh so in um uh let's pitch wait
you guys already did this you picked we
did this yesterday yeah can we pitch
some
Dave Batista romantic comedy movies but
the comedy movies are all porn parodies
of movies he's been in yes oh there's
not so that many can we do new movies uh
Guardians of the Galaxy that's one poon
poon
stopper knock at the back door knock at
the back door under 2049 [__] at the
back he was in Blade yeah
farmer with the glasses
James Bond pink eye um let it be known
that uh off-screen uh producer Samantha
just walks through the office 10 feet
away from us 10 feet away from the
blender holding her nose that's how
awful it smells in the office right now
she's spraying for breakfast our screen
producer dashel is about to hurl he has
yet to put anything in his mouth just
being around
that's what I took I don't know how you
guys are sitting here a cuttlefish
souffle okay
it's like WWE oh that's a good one
that's a good one oh so he was in um
what was the James Bond movie that he
was a villain I said pink eye but it was
a specter yeah it might have been I need
to go faster
in fact hurt [__] her okay sorry guys
okay also there are um I think this is
the spice this is what kind of spice is
this on top uh this is the uh everything
it's a it's actually a 24 spice blend
it's so fun which makes no sense it
smells like an outhouse I'm done
smelling them I'm done smelling them it
smells like Funyuns in a fart this is
day eight at Burning Man Outhouse where
they've been sitting in the hot sun they
haven't been cleaned okay you've been
doing whatever you do at Burning Man
this is coming out of you so do we need
more water I I'm still good I have a
full thing I need a Catholic prayer now
now you're concerned about our
well-being Evan thanks a lot okay uh to
you Trey Wharton
there was so much Wasabi in that
yeah try doing the outro
all right
Tommy no one can see you when you're in
the corner
I'm gonna make sauce
Tommy's about to make sauce
oh my god oh so interesting now there's
like a little heat to it because of
wasabi
no
and it's just like the dairy just makes
everything just coat my stomach feels
like it's trying to like separate the
dairy so it's like bubbly I don't know
how you guys are like it's it's rumbly
jumbling
I took three more of these than you two
who care about your stomach I'm just now
getting the root beer is coming back up
too I think it's like the dairy makes it
stay up here and the root beer makes
sure it comes back up here oh me
kill me okay well the best news is that
we did not get to the super crazy hot
sauce thank you all
um that would have ruined both Tommy and
I you know it's still one of the worst
days of my life was when we ate the
Pocky chip well I liked it because we
kissed a little it's time for mandatory
fun oh no oh I completely forgot I'm so
sorry
wait wasn't that the headlines no that
was just a fun little segment we did
called break room update this is
mandatory fun
the segment where I gather my three best
friends
what are you guys doing this weekend
what's everybody doing this weekend
the play oh okay the musical nice I'm
going hiking seeing the whale
if he went on a few hikes
I can say that
Thomas ask my doctor I could say that
I'm in the same category Thomas
prosthetic I'm gonna be uh flossing 400
times oh my God there's so much ocean
life in my frontal mouth right now
oh it's like I went down on Ariel
You Wish You Wish You Wish Whole New
World everything's better or I went down
on I went down on Stromboli or whatever
the whale from Pinocchio is
um real quick what are some important
parodies of some of the songs uh from
Little Mermaid
um kiss the girls ass part of that world
kiss the girl's ass
all right well thank you all for not
making us drink an entire bottle of the
bombs in that smoothie no thank you all
for the 904 that you donated which I
believe is a new record for this show I
mean we had people you know jumping in
from Canada Europe all kinds of
different denominations of things Elia
fui Murano I hope I'm saying your name
right everybody else uh I mean I guess
I'm thankful but also shame on you we
appreciate those contributions for sure
Trey Warden say your full name never
okay Scott Warden I'm not doing that I
don't know uh this fooled me again three
times he's gonna appear in the mirror
real quick shout out again check out
nerd riot.shop for these and other very
cool shirts there's like six different
quantumania designs there's only one
reason I'm not covered in puke right now
it's because I got this fresh clean tea
and I ain't gonna ruin it uh and oh God
I can't look at it uh two big things
coming up for us uh one come back Sunday
hey yo come big Sunday Jessica Brandon
Anna gonna be
um doing a reaction show for the fourth
episode of The Last of Us the best
goddamn thing on TV right now
um and stop making so much noise tell me
it will not live through the night uh
and then a week from this Sunday I feel
you Hank we're gonna have uh there's a
dog freaking out in the office it's
chaos
um and then a week we're gonna be doing
here we announced and we announced our
team oh my God
all right here's I I'll announce right
now because I'm so bad I'm very close to
hurling here's our Super Bowl plans
camera four I'm gonna lose a bunch of
money on the game but I'm also gonna
watch all the commercials and trailers
and we're going live right after me and
a bunch of my boys who knows if we'll
have been drinking who knows what else
will have done you may be full of
disgusting Seafood snacks again no no I
hope not yes I'll probably never enjoy
shrimp again
certainly not dried shrimp the way I
used to enjoy it uh but yeah so a week
from this Sunday
it's gonna be a very special Sunday two
break room episodes on that Sunday a
last of us after show and immediately
following the Super Bowl We'll Be Live
reacting to all the we know we're
getting trailers for fasting The Flash
probably a Disney plus type but we take
a fair amount of Disney stuff thankfully
Sony is gonna sit this one out
uh it's gonna take a time out save save
2.5 million dollars yes and and probably
a couple of things that we don't even
know about yet so we're really excited
for that so we'll be going live and
maybe we'll we'll make some sports
themed uh jokes as well if you see me in
the streets this weekend stay away
because I'm straight up Eel and shrimp
can you imagine what my stuff and feces
are gonna smell like in the next 48
hours I can't I wish I wasn't going to
that pee and poo party tonight
will you guys jump on my stomach till I
puke all this out of me is that what you
want have a great weekend everybody
yeah what's that
xenix
endless mic coming in off the top rope
at the end no we already said our
goodbyes yeah it's too late
it's too late
I thought I thought I was out and you
pulled me back in
oh my God I feel so bad you know I'll do
a small shot of just the hot sauce
because I'm I'm
sure yeah I'll do I'll do just hot sauce
because I'm a man of integrity okay
could mine be mostly shrimp challenge I
will take a hot shot and again this
final level is the hottest outside the
hottest hot sauce from the hot ones
official package let's try some berries
and ice cream in there too you know
let's put maybe it's a little more look
at the level of the thing Rising is it
oh
uh this is like a thimble of this is
like what a waste of sauce it's so
viscous I think we need a little more we
need more milk and again there's still
many townsman said go see Dr nasty okay
Dr nasty is gonna need to get he's gonna
have to give him freaking rhinoceros
again there's still as long as there's
no Dairy there's still sardines in there
eel uh dried shrimp uh cuttlefish Wasabi
uh sauerkraut or ice cream
all right broccoli what Have We Become
haven't healed me with your eyes cut to
the to the to the mixture
who's enjoying this look at the chunks
those are berries that looks like what's
going to come out of us later yeah Sam
you also have to take a shot of it Sam
you don't want to be a part of this life
get out of here
stop cutting to it oh God
I'd rather swallow geology
and also for the people that love to
comment on these videos I'm just here
for Eric Voss uh full movie breakdowns
well this is what you get you know and
we're never gonna stop doing this next
week I'm gonna need a human
toes to tits
as it was a lady here well I don't know
that is true everybody's got him
I'm so afraid of this
that are saying like why not like we've
got nothing why not I'm in so much pain
I have some reasons why not
I want to go out there and have a like a
happy life after this Ryan P uh Rowdy
townsman coming back trash bag in the
chat
uh you're gonna want to call Shabazz
Shabazz after this too look at me oh my
God I guess it was Betty White that's
been doing me dirty those are my shot
glasses
you're Betty White which is a good one
Betty why I love you so much
how does it still smell so much like eel
I don't know the eel is really an
overpowered I feel like I've eaten two
cans worth of eels eel ingredients so
much and it's so much okay
go go go go go go go go go go go go go
go the spice is unheard of the spices
unheard of
the spice is immediately
oh oh
devastating I have a charlie horse in my
hands my ass immediately cramped up on
me I haven't done it yet I'm so scared I
got a horse ass oh it's not going away
it's not good it's not the spice is
immediate no I don't want to do it oh
God I'm so scared it's not going away
I'm finding everybody on this list
I'm going to your house oh no anything
literally make you drink this drink in
front of me no
broccoli just give it around the last
episode Teddy broccoli broccoli
oh it's so spicy
but it's still eel it's so eely
it's like a spicy eel uh we're never
gonna be the same uh next week there'll
be four new hosts
um
amendments
snacky huddle stamps oh my God and Ron
backbold look I only got a quarter of it
down
oh I got every hot sauce down the hand I
need the broccoli it's still there
oh
I don't know if my I don't know if I can
bother children anymore oh medically I'm
not sure yeah let me just hollowed out
my ovaries oh my ovaries are shot too
after that but get away from me
have a great weekend
cut the camera
[Music]